shake my hand you [ __ ] I'm Mattie
Andrea and this is car collectors and
Galvan auto sports we do all areas of
customizing for literally all makes and
models basically if you can dream it we
can build it and we do anything custom
Oh buddy man see you again good to see
you too
thank you for inviting me over anytime
kalpen Auto Sport collection this is one
of the best places in Southern
California to check out muscle cars and
your whole line of galvanized cars you
guys been building over the years let's
go take a look at them
well we do and I are huge Mustang fans
you know this and I know you love these
Shelby's yes tell me about this Shelby
Mustang this is 65 GT 350 and it was
literally put in a guy's garage and
storage for over 40 years and untouched
it's a true barn find we left all the
patina on it inside and out but we got
it running like a clock so it drives
beautifully this is one of the greatest
cars I think in your collection so these
are some of our galvanized vehicles this
was in the movie kick-ass it's the red
mist mobile so kind of cool yeah oh this
is the car my kids love our Focus RS and
one of the fastest best handling cars
you could ever drive this is our Focus
ST that we did for SEMA this year we
actually do a whole custom wide body kit
really emulate the rally cars of today
as a street car version of it and this
is our 66 Bronco one of my favorite
projects this is truly a custom inside
and out it was all hand-built everything
from the suspension all the interior
functions and it's got an awesome 302
engine and it is just so powerful
I love the gulf colors you'd never think
it would work on the Bronco but it does
and it just came out great when I first
saw it I knew we had a winner and so for
everyone that's seen it has absolutely
loved it this has to be one of the
craziest custom cars that you guys ever
made it keeps getting better and better
every year tell me what is this
this is sign it's twin supercharged
thousand horsepower super crazy custom
car that was actually based on a Mustang
our idea was let's come up with a modern
crazy show car that not only showcased
design but also technology how do you
how do you open it can you open it up
everything's on voice command so sighs
doors open voice activation how do you
drive this thing that there's no
steering wheel well depends if you want
a left-hand drive or a right-hand drive
depending what country you're in so for
you we'll hit the button that activates
the steering and now your pedals are
activated as well
twin superchargers a thousand horsepower
scare the [ __ ] out but I love about this
place is it's a big toy store and
everything in here is for sale except
for one car and that's my baby this is
my very first car 65 Mercedes 220 se and
the first car that I ever customized
used to be green on green yeah and now
it's black with leopard skin interior
the leopard skin that was your idea that
was my idea
yeah you got to tell me what is this
crazy thing right next to it well that's
just Liberace's Zimmer it's got to be
one of the all-time tackiest cars and
you know what's not to love about that I
love it
bow thank you so much it's been an
absolute pleasure my pleasure big album
collection is really amazing and what
you guys can do with these cars is is
incredible I'm blown away every time I
come by here you guys are always pushing
the limits on stuff so thank you once
again my pleasure
for even more great videos subscribe to
GQ calm and don't forget let us know
what you want to see on car collectors